hey Conan here I know everyone's been
anxiously awaiting my YouTube video
response to one Direction's perfume
release video so here it is and sorry
for the delay
basically when I was told that One
Direction made a video about releasing a
perfume I was thrilled I thought this
will be great it sounds fascinating it
sounds exciting it sounds uplifting and
fun and then I watched the video and to
my horror that music that they're
playing in the background is the most
depressing dirge I've ever heard it just
seems like an incredibly bizarre musical
choice I looked into it and that song is
playing in the background
true story that's the music the ASPCA
plays and their ads when they're trying
to get you to adopt an abused animal
they just took that music and I don't
think that was the way to go
don't misunderstand I have nothing
against one direction I don't know who
they are I'm assuming they're I think
they're chimney sweeps
or maybe probably a an affable band of
pickpockets in London hello guvnah but
your pocket I did little Watchi Watchi
they seemed like a nice group of young
scamp's and I wish them well but I just
wish they had gone with different music
because I want to die now after watching
that anyway subscribe to my channel
you